[Music]
just discovered that i may have a son
here in this land
how much child support are she getting
from the king pays no child support no
child support for 30 years and you came
back
use a dummy
here hello i
he's supposed to be like the prince of
wakanda wakanda is a fictional place not
everybody so munda is a very
[Applause]
and his moms children this is your
brother
hey kwai i'm sorry i slept with your man
this happened before we even met
it's not like you're the first man i've
ever been with
what did you just say about the other
men coming to america now he's coming to
me
i always thought that mika was going to
be queen a woman isn't allowed to lose
amunda it's the law
did it ever occur to you that megan
wanted to be your heir
would you dare banish me from my own
bedroom
[Applause]
[Music]
you must be strong and general izzy
would love nothing more than to take
over zamunda
[Laughter]
i'm a king put your hands together like
that
say it again i must admit
your style is far into my kingdom but
it's impressive that's right there you
go
let me hear you say hey ho hey ho no
don't do that that's his mother
oh don't you say no not to his mother
almost ready to become a prince almost
it is time
ceremonial circumcision prince power
royal
mercedes ain't gonna sharpen you too
nephew
coming to america now it's coming to me
[Music]
you